When the framework can run in the
background it is said to be thread safe.
However, there are several frameworks
that are not thread safe and
can only run in the main queue.
There or
two notable cases in the apple stack.
These are two banana peels waiting for
a newbie to step on them.
These are UIKit and Core data.
Let's start with UIKit.
You cannot run anything from
UIKit in the background, or
your app will crash intermittently.
That's the beauty of concurrency bugs.
Sometimes they show up,
sometimes they don't.
The bottom line is never use
anything who's name ends with
view in the background.
Or else.
Core data is a bit more complicated, and
we will deal with this in greater
detail once we reach core data.
The thing to remember here is
that ns manage object context
can only be used in the same
queue it was created.
Therefore, if you created
the context in the main queue,
you may only use it in the main queue.
However, if you create
a context in a background que,
then you may only use
it in the background.
My recommendation is to wait until we
feel really confident with core data and
GCD before you try to mix them together.
Core data in the background is second
than core data, so tread carefully,
Daniel son.
Until then, wax on wax off.
Remember to breath, very important, hai.